you already know what it is man bootleg
Capcom real 92.3 and Machine Gun Kelly
the young gunner the Alpha Omega alive
in a charge from Phoenix Arizona having
[ __ ] to you perform I like thinking both
your finger on stage tonight
and you kept having to tape it while you
were playing guitars are how do you like
performer pain like that I feel like it
happens more often and I've seen you
perform on crutches I'll tell your much
day on crack oh no no crap I was living
it no I mean Paul literally like shut up
how do you get through the pain like you
know is it the adrenaline is it just did
I think man I think I'm ready to die on
stage every time I go up there and I
think like I you know my friend said to
me a zombie mod is opening for me every
night out here on the tour he told me he
was like man when I watch you it looks
like you're like it looks like you're
like doing therapy it looks like you're
like exercising your demons and [ __ ] you
know I'm saying like I don't I feel numb
man like every time I'm up on stage so
like even this I mean this having what
like 30 minutes ago like [ __ ] man I
still can't even feel it professional I
don't know I'm ready to give it all for
this [ __ ] look man um general admission
and extremely slept on album when people
were talking about hip hop out for sure
I'm mad cuz I got here late I missed you
before my world series announced which
is a great album you first number-one
album
obviously on the radio side or in the
commercial side maybe like
was frustrating that that some of the
records that were on the project that
you thought that it goes out thought you
had a couple hits on there so I thought
I did something - I mean how frustrating
is that when the Machine doesn't like
match up - when you go out and you know
you obviously you see on social media
you go to these shows and it's crazy and
it could be crazier does it get
frustrating sometimes [ __ ] the Machine I
am the machine that's a perfect album
anyone who missed out is gonna find out
about it anyway man that's a perfect
album that I'll never I'll never make
another I don't like it and I'm not
supposed to that was like that was my
marshmallows LP that was my gibber about
trying that was the one that was it that
was general mission was lyrically the
best I've ever been I was the best
representation point personally now it's
my job to go out there and break
barriers in other ways that I want to
and keep itching my creativity you know
keep keep scratching my creative edge
excuse me um I am quite jealous because
I know of a couple of porn actresses
that you have smashed that we talked
about in the past definitely some chicks
on my spank bank have you knocked down
any horns have you hung out with any new
porn stars lately I should say I'm just
saying hung out I don't want you to UM
that new crib I got the big Boulevard
that's like just like the hangout spot
in LA man all the people be coming
through that way you got a criminal anus
yeah I don't know that's called the
boulevard it's called the boulevard I
mean baked bullet but Peters called the
boulevard you know you had the boulevard
like no one knocks he's walking every
night walking around tomorrow everybody
everywhere like everybody Lynn and there
yeah that's crazy
I was talking to Tommy Lee the other
days with the tree houses or just coming
through oh man that's a legendary yeah
he's dead I probably my favorite MTV
Cribs ever when it was all goes so great
sure nuts
talk about him Autzen on the on the tour
obviously you've shot couple videos at
his crib I'm he's one of the like
coolest yeah who'd you ever meet I mean
speaking of like general admission that
he was out there when we did like the
creator for like the cover and all
subjects we took we took DMT in the
desert just crazy and I would like
survive
he thought almost hold on wait hit he
thought watching uh hey-oh
with a matzah wit yeah grab grab my I
wanted to dnt [ __ ] I only been ma
where's that crazy mummy am I've
destroyed her [ __ ] Vegas hotel room
two weeks ago I did right before was at
10:38 was it room 21 at Hard Rock Hotel
no it was at a Kazuma Swede me and my
remember I remember that was the miners
destroy 10:28 no I remember the first
time you came to Vegas
oh we destroyed that that was it oh that
was a hard rock though I'm surprised to
let you back that we put the home awhile
there they did they ban me for a couple
years
when have you got anyone let me go tell
her if he ain't nowhere so I'll get
anyway um so moving on from outside
obviously he's the [ __ ] well what he was
gonna tell you was that he thought I was
gonna kill him with a knife in the
desert because you guys did DMT was this
scent like like yucca yucca forest with
some [ __ ] did you guys go to Joshua Tree
into Josh choice yeah Joshua Tree that's
late that's like all [ __ ] entourage
talk about what you're working on right
now you just put out this new single bad
things which you know I think you've had
a couple of hits man I think this could
really be the one though that takes off
on how do you feel about the record and
what's the new stuff you record us out
in life
um I think the new stuff um Saturday
report the new stuff I'm recording
sounds like like fun like sounds like
what I wanted to sound you know me I've
experienced love and heartbreak they
don't mean it's a different type of pain
that I like and that's my specialty you
know taking pain and converting that
energy into creativity and lyrics and my
come on we talked about the time I
thought he was gonna stab you in the
desert oh man here we go again
wait you should have just loved you
should just let me say Oh what do you
think it was what did you think was
gonna happen meet you in the desert when
we did the MT to go okay here's all
breaks down no give him one Center what
did you think out what do you think was
gonna happen we did the empty in the
desert together house looked at me in
the eyes and said I brought you out here
to kill you
oh [ __ ] okay tell us verbatim quote that
I'll never forget is my you're a happy
little [ __ ] when you do drugs he
brings out the best in you when I do
drugs it brings out the dark side where
the desert and full is addicted to
knives food and throws knives in the air
and things like crazy wet you never
someone but when someone's like [ __ ]
up on [ __ ] it doesn't matter like how
dope you are we're not [ __ ] up when
you're throwing knives around [ __ ] up
in the middle of desert pitch-black no
scary [ __ ] I didn't talk to him for like
48 hours I was literally like stale as
[ __ ] like really how folks are at home
and he didn't talk through the holes are
cuz I've literally he looked at me it
was like I'm gonna kill you and it like
[ __ ] me up
it was that it [ __ ] up the vibe cows
will [ __ ] do that you ready controls
the vibe bro especially in the middle of
a desert which we are tonight you don't
know what the [ __ ] going up is we're
gonna get it in tonight I start
pardon an extra manner and [ __ ] [ __ ]
finger um but now was asking like
obviously you got the new single out
let's go for fit arm out hey love um I
think like general admission was like I
could talk with those action
marshmallows oh my god it's kind of like
what the first time should have been as
a fans yeah I totally did I totally um
what's the new [ __ ] sounded like that
was the motivation out you know what I'm
saying like the motivation and I know
what you mean by that the motivation
your meaning is the pain right because
that's what right that's what you want
that's why that's what you get scared ah
artist is gonna lose beautiful thing
about it on this album is that I fell in
love for the first time I got heart
broke for the first time you know what
I'm saying like these all happen in the
last yes yes no has year yeah like and
you know and that relationship with
something over the past two years so it
really culminated with in the past like
six months where this huge free like
songwriting you know convicted Hardwick
always brings the best meets amazing
yeah it's amazing then so I mean you
know that and then just I think it's me
Korea like I just continuing express
himself not being scared I'm done with
people like the the me that I wasn't I
came in the game like I never gave a
[ __ ] or anyone says like I used to look
like I look at my old tweets and I'm
like [ __ ] dude I'll just tweet anything
I felt like saying like no one here no
but this you know what I'm saying like
I'm back to that man I don't care mount
care how politically corrected when I
don't give a [ __ ] did when I die I'm
dead oh gee MGK [ __ ] right there
[ __ ] you that's how I was that's how I'm
back to the dicks you know I looked in
the mirror and I say I am that's it do
you have a damn done first of all this
[ __ ] has I am just I had two
right there straight up straight up
[ __ ] did you show that I am bruh
take me as I am all right
[ __ ] your [ __ ] your opinion man I'm me
[ __ ] you do you you you you're you near
you by [ __ ] I am so let me be
me I'm here and I'm come done oh okay yo
perfect know is album done of I was the
album is yeah I'm done
no it's not yeah yes yeah you know what
[ __ ] yes cuz if you know what I did I
did all the music that represents that
time period when I was home at the
boulevard that vibe
was there so take that I'm 26 years old
I'm gonna write a million more albums
and you know that album is from that
month you know tank there take that next
one is no next violin like you know I
don't I don't cut slack so it will be it
will be my version of perfect but if you
know we have a title I don't and I'm
just I just I want to be introspective
and something amazing and I just keep
[ __ ] begging for it keep taking the
universe for if you take the DMT go back
to Joshua Tree I'm up with the album
name I know anyway you know the singles
out bad things go get it on iTunes
leaves be on the lookout for this guy
he's gonna be running around town yo man
I'm proud of you dawg thanks keV and
stop [ __ ] breaking my right right item
this [ __ ] reckless man you
already know perfect